rencontres et échanges entre les
professionnels de santé sur le cancer
c'était l'objectif de la table ronde
organisée vendredi 9 décembre à l'ufr
des sciences de l'université versailles
saint quentin
le but renforcer la lutte contre le
cancer dans les yvelines
on s'est aperçus qu'au niveau de notre
agglomération ou d'un pourcentage quand
même de cancers du sein un peu plus
élevé que sur les autres agglomérations
découvrir l'institut de promotion de la
santé basée à trappes est engagé dans
cette lutte
son rôle développer la prévention et
faire connaître les offres de soins du
territoire avec l'accent qui est mis sur
le dépistage précoce pour permettre une
guérison efficace on souhaite multiplier
ses actions de prévention notamment par
le dépistage en sachant qu'il ya
d'autres voies pour pour la prévention
il faut également parler de notre ition
de diététique
il faut également parler de prévention
des addictions c'est faire en sorte que
les professionnels de santé connaissent
également toutes les ressources du
territoire puisse connaître également
la façon d'orienter au mieux et de façon
optimum les publics et passion en france
le taux de guérison et croissants en
2015 3 millions de français ont survécu
au cancer
[Applaudissements]